the european union has announced plans
to ban all imports of russian oil by the
end of the year it's part of a sixth
package of sanctions by the eu in
response to the war in ukraine the
sanctions are yet to be formally
approved by member states but countries
which are reliant on russian oil could
vote against it in her announcement of
the sanctions the european commission
president ursula von d'aleian said that
the eu simply has to do it
today we are addressing our dependency
on russian oil and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil but we simply
have to do it we will make sure that we
phase out russian oil in an orderly
fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
and this is why we will phase out
russian supply of crude oil within six
months
and we find products by the end of the
year
well let's get analysis on this from our
business presenter ian king six months
the end of the year not fast enough for
ukraine but it is going to mean moving
very very quickly for lots of different
countries in europe
yes that's right jane the reason that
they've put in these targets
the end of the year is really to give
countries more time in order to prepare
themselves for being weaned off russian
oil exports and refined products such as
kerosene and diesel um you mentioned
that uh this uh has to be voted through
unanimously by the european parliament
by uh every eu member well slovakia and
hungary have particular concerns because
of their higher dependence on russian
crude and i understand that the draft
documents put forward by the eu would
give slovakia and hungary until the end
of next year in order to get themselves
off russian crude so they would have
slightly more time but make no mistake
this is a very very big measure indeed
should it come to pass we talk a lot
jane about the importance of russian gas
to eu countries well actually they buy
much more oil from russia than they do
gas russia's overall crude exports last
year were expected to be this year on
current levels around 180 billion us
dollars so a very very significant sum
of money indeed the west by some 70
percent of that and the eu a big chunk
of it in all the eu relies on russia for
around 25
of its crude imports so this is why it
is such a big deal it would deprive the
kremlin of a lot of money the other
reason i think that the eu is staggering
this increa this measure and not
bringing it in straight away is because
they don't want to push up the oil price
suddenly which would inadvertently
potentially make even more money for
vladimir putin so that's why i think
there is going to be this phased
approach it's part of a number of other
measures that have been introduced by
the eu today they've also announced that
spur bank which is russia's biggest bank
is being kicked off the swift system
which is a communications messaging
system that helps facilitate
cross-border money transfers around the
world and it's also banning three
russian broadcasters from the eu's
airways they've also incidentally as
part of this package named several
individuals who they think are
responsible for the massacre in bucco
recently and uh that is something that
angela van der lion stated in her
address to the european parliament
earlier this morning but as i say it is
this measure on oil that is the real
showstopper a lot of people will be
skeptical as to whether this will work
they will say well hang on won't russia
just sell more crude to other countries
at a knock down price and indeed we do
know that they've been doing that with
recent oil embargoes from the uk and the
united states there has been some
evidence of russia trying to sell its
oil cheaply to china and india for
example but they have a problem in doing
that for a start as i said earlier on
most of their crude exports currently go
to the west so there will be a challenge
in getting it across to buyers in the
east there is one pipeline that runs
from russia to china for oil but so that
would effectively mean that those uh
exports would have to be done by by
seabourn methods in other words by big
oil tankers and there's a question there
whether the carriers the owners the
shipping companies the tanker owners
would necessarily want to do that they'd
be risking for example being punished
for sanctions busting by some counts
they also would find their insurance
premiums very very high because a lot of
those crude exports would have to go via
black sea ports and we've seen for
example how effective the ukrainians
have been to attacking the russian navy
so there'd be challenges there as well
but overall it's a big big measure
ian thanks very much